hey guys Doug Walker here just me again
sailing rods not able to make this one
not under protest this time he just can
fit into a schedule and in terms of bomb
review I'm gonna try and get one out
later this week on a Sin City it's um
just a lot of stuffs coming up and I
will do my best I can't promise anything
but I'll do my best
uh but yeah we're gonna talk about sin
city a dame to kill for and yeah of
course like everything that's in
theaters now you can't talk about until
you talk about the original which is
just been so weird I always had to talk
about what I thought the original it's
not like oh what's this let me just tell
you about anywho um the the first Sin
City movie hell's go the comics I read
the comics a little bit growing up
mostly love the art where art works just
amazing it still holds up really well
and you know the stories were fine
they're just really grim film noir
over-the-top comic book style stuff and
then the movie came out yeah well like
nine years ago something like that a
long time ago and I loved it I just fell
in love with this movie and I totally
acknowledge its adolescent
testosterone-filled bullshit its total
nonsense
um but it's so stylized and I argue
there's a little bit more than just a
bunch of violence and it is violent I
think it might be the most consistently
violent movie ever see in my life I
don't think a minute goes by without
some form of violence happening it's
quite astounding um but at the same time
what I liked about is that like the marv
character is one of my favorite
characters like ever I love both the
simplicity and the complexity of him
just this loser nobody who hangs out in
a strip bar but he's a tough guy then
like solely his life has meaning just
because someone was nice to him and it's
like I love that stuff and I think
that's what I like about Sin City is
that it even though it is over-the-top
and violent and super dark and gritty it
finds that simplicity that matters or at
least will keep your attention I can't
think of anyone that would at least with
the marv story start it and then be like
now I don't
need to see what happens is enough
everyone we need to see what happens and
you can't predict what's gonna happen um
and and I like the I like the Dwight
story too and I like the Bruce Willis
story so I really like the movie and I
know it's childish and and and silly but
there's it's just the right marks uh in
my opinion its stylized it's it you
never see film noir anymore this is so
in-your-face film noir and I've waited
years for a sequel I was like well I
didn't this one just pop up well why did
he have to make whatever Spy Kids for
Sharkboy and Lavagirl or say you know
whatever he does or machete five and
finally this movie has come out it's not
doing very well with critics I think it
has like 40 percent or something like
that and I think it's almost as good as
the first one I think if you want to see
a Sin City movie that is exactly what
you get with this and I saw it at the
Hollywood Boulevard whatev advertised
before it's a great theater and you can
get food and alcohol with it and this is
a movie you want food and alcohol I
think I got like a steak and like a beer
and I'm just watching this it's just a
gyro you go I mean it's but the nice
thing is that unlike a lot of stuff like
um like I said with you know that I hate
to keep going back to them but it's just
the heat such an easy target with
Michael Bay you know K well how can you
like Sin City and not transformers
they're both the same
testosterone-filled nonsense and there
is a difference Sin City is very
stylized it's beautiful to look at it's
reminiscent of an art form that's
practically dead film noir and it pushes
it to an all-new extreme that you never
really saw him film the water and where
everyone always says Michael Bay
oh well Michael Bay is extreme he's
really not not like this not in an
entertaining way uh extreme is pushing
something you know to a whole new level
and Michael Bay's doing the same thing
over and over there's no variety no
difference
since city is so extreme and so
in-your-face and is pushing it to this
new level like I said first film I think
there was like a punch a minute there
was
always some form of violence going on
and that's not always the best you know
but it is pushing this stereotype to
just this whole new extreme where it
almost becomes a new art form uh and
it's just a silly it's just as grim it's
just as dark if there's just as much
nudity and if there's just as much
violence um as soon as the movie started
I mean for example there's one of the
lines in the movie is I wake up in
midair and I'm greeted with a
good-morning kiss by the concrete ground
I mean where it transformers is there
anything like that and the whole movie
is written like that all that's really
stylized uh this this really dark heavy
shadow wonderful angled uh film
it's kind of like you know Calvin Hobbs
when he played was Sam Spade or whatever
we pretended he was the detective it's
like it's like that kid both never grew
up and grew up at the same time it's
like he has the same fantasies only now
you incorporate the really really
violent you know and the horny stuff too
because there's naked women all over the
place
sneaky guys too but they don't it's
double standards it's like no we can't
show their ditch now ladies Tatas that's
fine but you can't do that nothing I
want to see their tits
I'm fine not seeing Bruce Willis's
schlong but it's like in this film they
really push it cuz like um is the scene
where Dwight is naked for quite a long
time it James Brolin plays and then it's
like okay in the first film Bruce Willis
is naked too but it's like the light
hits a way where it's like okay like I
could just by not seeing that but it
here he's like flying around all over
the place like an explosion something
happens he flies off a window and he's
still butt-naked or just this convenient
shadow right there and I'm like okay
this is come on guys and you know in the
comic they drew everything and show and
everything but like no you we can show
the people ooh you know ole's taught us
that that's a work of art but the
penises Lulu which is true the penis is
a hideous thing but at the same time
it's like it's a double standard it's
not fair if you're gonna do one in this
movie of extremism go all the way um
I yeah it's uh it's so silly and it's
got a lot more actors that belong in
this world
it's got James Brolin who is um such a
better Dwight
I'm sorry Clive oh and your your great
actor you can you're wonderful in drama
I'm talking to him like he's got to see
this but uh I enjoy Clive Owen in dramas
I never bought him as the badass I
always saw performance and that's like
the one thing in Sin City I'm like it
you don't quite fit like you're you're
giving it your all but it's like you
don't fit Mickey Rourke is a badass
Billy or a Bruce Willis is a badass I I
buy that you know they can just walk in
you're just like whoa this guy's fucking
awesome um a Clive Owen always seem like
he's acting tough he's just go squinty
eyes go yeah and it I don't know some
about when Bruce Willis quinces his eyes
and goes yeah I believe it more but to
each their own um I really like this new
Dwight a lot more uh Joseph
gordon-levitt is in it he's great uh we
get a lot more of like the name we get a
lot more than Nancy character from the
first film which is like you not that
she was a bad character or anything was
just her like okay the the hot chick and
she's got a little bit of a backstory
but whatever is mostly Bruce Willis's
story and they give her a lot of story
in this and it's it's pretty cool like
they they make her this legitimate
badass and then she's like cutting
herself up and everything she's got
scars and let's go kill some bastards
it's like it it's pretty awesome
um and the stories are still most of
them are sad endings again just like Sin
City uh but there's such this even
though it's over-the-top and extreme
there is still such this poetry in it
and it's the kind of poetry you find in
film noir and you find in extreme
situations and I don't know it's worth
experiencing like the second this movie
started I felt at home I know it sounds
really weird to say but with the shadows
with the angles with the dialogue with
the characters uh while it is simplistic
they know just the right lines and just
the right scenes to show
to keep you invested and to hit you um
there's a scene ray Liotta's in this
again great choice Christopher Lloyd is
blocking him is it's like all these
people yes yes thank you for putting
them in Sin City um there's a scene
where Ray Liotta he gets done making
love with his prostitute and he's
putting his gun together and she say you
know I won't tell anyone and he says you
know I know you well I'd really know you
won't but would you keep your mouth shut
if they tortured you they did all these
terrible things too you know I'm so
sorry and it's like just like those few
lines you kind of you get these people's
characters really quick I think that's
what's clever about it it's that
especially in comics and comics are
probably even though it's the same
amount dialogue it feels longer because
most of things are done through pictures
but in a movie it's everything is on
this fast pace and with those very
cleverly chosen words and those chosen
lines uh you get these characters really
fast and I think that's part of the fun
is that they always know just what
scenes and they know just what to show
and then move on to the next thing they
don't waste time and again it's not a
three-hour epic as I know we're just
gonna boom boom boom get to it but the
character isn't glanced over it's only
hitting the essential stuff but the
atmosphere of the world makes up for the
rest you know if you're ever like man
doesn't this film ever slow down you're
just enjoying the layout so much and the
choice of what they colorize and what
they don't and if I had any problems
with the film there's two problems one
is the exact same problem with the first
film and that's the Twite story goes on
too long which is so strange it's so
strange that in both films that's a
problem and they're maybe cuz they're
both in the middle I don't know maybe I
just finally start to get a little tired
but yeah that's in both films I'm always
like really a little bit my watch when
you know the two white story is sort of
like you know you're getting close to
the end or at the middle uh so that's
one problem and the other problem which
sadly is a major one it doesn't end on a
strong note the first film
not super cleverly but still managed to
bookend itself
it starts off if you don't know it's a
bunch of different stories it's easy in
yets that take place in Sin City a lot
of them are somehow connected in one way
or another and in in the first film it
starts off with this character and the
character makes a return at the end
which is tied into another character
we're introduced to which it's not like
wow what a mind blow or anything like
that but at the same time you'd sort of
it wraps it up it feels like this is a
complete film this film doesn't have
that and the ending for all these really
big whoa you know like dramatic endings
that happen usually usually sad endings
um we get this ending and it's the setup
it's pretty much this character wants
revenge the character gets revenge roll
the credits and you saw wait where's the
where's the wait that you were promising
there where's the wait that was in all
the other stories uh and it's such a
bizarre note to end on because it again
we're with the first one you felt like
with every single one and even the last
one you felt like man I saw movie but
they were all so short stories and they
all had an impact and they all felt
pretty heavy the last one is just sort
of like a minor story that stops nice
and say it ends but doesn't end on a
really big note and you're wrapping up
four or five stories here so I cannot
feel like that might leave a bad taste
in people's mouths you know like that
might actually have someone struggling
or was the point of that movie and it's
not that the home the movies or the the
movie or the shorts didn't have a point
it's that they didn't end it on the
right note and of God every filmmaker
knows this it's like the the last note
is the most important one that's what
you leave the people on why didn't you
bookend it or why didn't you give a big
finish why did just something uh so that
was a shame there maybe maybe there was
something there they thought they had to
cut it I don't know but the ending is
really lacking that that that's a sad
part of it but everything else if if you
enjoy the first Sin City you'll probably
like this one the only
I can think that would also maybe be a
problem is that a lot of characters are
returning characters and going into this
I thought I was gonna get all new
characters you know callek in the first
film they'd always be a new character
with each one and a lot of them are
returning there's only one or two new
ones and they are great they are cool um
but it's mostly return characters but
again I like these characters I love to
see more Marv and it's great seeing him
is gracing of just when he is just lost
and sort of rambling and just go on any
mission or whatever you know before he
has his purpose like in the first film
so and maybe that could be a draw for
some people and yeah I think very
obviously if I see watch 10 minutes of
the first film if you don't like it
you're not gonna like this one either
and and if you're wondering if you can
see this film without seeing the first
one I wouldn't recommend it you can
technically but a lot of what makes it
work is knowing who these people are
going to be or who they were in the
previous film so I think it does make a
difference you can still follow it
enough but it's it's better if you see
the first one and I saw with a great
crowd people were laughing at all the
right moments they were cheering at all
the right moments they were you know
they're even laughing at moments that
maybe were supposed to be taken
seriously but that's the great thing
about it it's a film you go into and
it's you don't have to take it seriously
it you can watch it either as this
die-hard comedy or this diehard action
filming you can enjoy it either way uh
so I loved it and my guess is anyone
that really likes the first film will
probably get into this there's not a ton
of new stuff but the world is still just
as grand just as great even more clear
there are some parts where they cut back
to the original film and you can tell us
a little bit of a grain in this so they
they updated the the cameras and the
equipment too so it looks even better
and it's it's just so beautiful on the
big screen I may even go back and see it
again because it is just so beautiful to
look at the ligers I think there's a
little bit more than just
style over substance I think there is
still that simplicity to carrying out a
mission what you're fighting for what
you're dying for and it's it's not a lot
but it's just enough to satisfy like
both an action film and a film noir it
it hits just enough um at least for me
it maybe it doesn't for you but yeah I
saved you like the first one check it
out you probably won't be disappointed
so that's about it hopefully I have a
bum review with you if not I'll just
take those robots worth I'll talk to you
later
take care